good afternoon
it is a pleasure for me to welcome
dr peter velikovic who is going to
deliver
a talk on theoretical foundation of
graph neural networks
better started in 2012
as undergraduate at the computer
laboratory
i remember i received an email around
may uh 2014 uh
and he he was asking for a part two
project
in bioinformatics then
the phd and
his uh his examiner um
was yura leskovic
and immediately after submission of it
is
he started with deep mind he is now
a senior research scientist peter
is all these audience
400 people are
going to listen to you thank you very
much pietro for the fine introduction
and uh thank you so much for
showing up in such big numbers uh i'm
truly humbled and i see so many people i
know so it's a
really a pleasure and an honor to be
back to the computer lab even if it's
virtual
and to talk to you all about uh one of
the topics that i've been most
passionate about over the past few years
and
as i've grown to understand the field
more and more i've also sort of tried to
improve the way i present the whole
field so i hope that you will find
today's exposition interesting
regardless of whether you're a seasoned
g
n particu practitioner or someone who's
just getting started with with the area
of graph representation learning
so in this talk we will be covering
neural networks that operate over graph
structure data or
they're more popularly known as graph
neural networks or gnns for short
first if you haven't come across the
area before i would like to give you a
little bit of an overview on
why might be why might it be a good idea
to study them
by giving you an example of just a few
fantastic graph neural nets you can find
in the wild nowadays
the first and perhaps the most direct
example i like to give is the case of
molecular data processing
so you might fairly obviously see that
molecules can be naturally represented
as
graphs you can look at here the molecule
for paracetamol and look at the
different
atoms of the molecule as nodes and the
molecular bonds as edges connecting them
and then you can meaningfully attach
some features to both the atoms and the
bonds such as the atom type the charge
the bond type
are we located in a ring or not and so
on and so forth
so once you've featurized the molecule
in this way one very interesting
question you can ask
a machine learning system is is this
molecule going to be a potent drug
and uh one particular way in which you
can pose that question is a binary
classification problem so taking a
representation of a molecule as you have
it
you can ask a gnn will this molecule
inhibit a certain bacterium for example
a shariah e coli
and then once you have set up a task
like that with a training data set of uh
molecules with known responses to e coli
you can train a graph classification
system
using a g n to predict whether or not
this bacteria is inhibited
now one thing that's really cool about
this is that once you've trained the
system like that you can meaningfully
apply it to any molecule even the ones
you haven't seen in your training data
so you can now execute your system on a
large data set of known possible drug
candidates
and your model will give you some
probabilities that those previously
unseen drugs
are going to inhibit e coli you can
select the top 100 candidates and then
ship them to chemists and have them
thoroughly investigated and it just
might happen that in these top 100
candidates
lies a highly potent antibiotic that was
previously overlooked by researchers in
the area
here i've shown you one such example of
a compound that was discovered in this
way which is halisin and uh
you know of course this is a very
important uh discovery of using graph
representation learning to detect
antibiotics so you obviously publish it
in a high impact journal
but then afterwards this basically kicks
up a bit of a
avalanche in the in the press so it gets
re-shared by nature
afterwards gets reported on by the
financial times by the bbc and so on
if you've seen at roughly the start of
last year
all of these titles like scientists
discover powerful antibiotic using ai
you can now know that actually
underneath all that ai
at the core is basically a graph neural
network so
this is still to this day probably the
most popularized application of graph
neural networks
now for a completely different example
which is much closer to what i've been
involved in lately
you can represent transportation
networks like the ones you see on google
maps
naturally as graphs you can look at
different nodes intersections and edges
as the roads connecting them and you can
put various interesting node features
like the lengths and speeds
onto these inputs and
within deepmind we have a very
successful collaboration with google
maps where we deployed a graph neural
network on
road networks constructed in this way to
predict what's the current estimated
time of arrival
which is obviously a very important
problem in transportation modeling
especially for a service like google
maps
and what's very interesting and as a
success story of gnns we've already
deployed the system
in several major cities around the world
you can see the picture on the right
explaining some of these cities and in
some of them such as sydney we have
reduced the percentage of negative
system predictions by over 40 so this is
also one example how
graph neural networks and graph
representation learning are affecting
basically billions of users every day if
you're in any of the major cities around
the world and you ask
for the shortest path from point a to
point b in google maps it's very likely
that your query will be passed through
our implemented graph neural network and
generally they're a very hot research
topic even outside of the
realm of applications graph neural
networks are regularly among the top and
fastest growing keywords for the
major machine learning conferences and
also represent
graph representation learning workshops
are regularly
the most attended one at conferences
like nerfs so gnns can be seen as
currently experiencing their image net
moment
and it's generally a very good point in
time to start studying them
and besides that you have a rich
ecosystem of libraries if you want to
get started with implementations
regardless of whether you use pytorch
tensorflow or jacks there is a library
that
can be found to suit your needs this
talk will be recorded and released so
you can check out the links afterwards
but rather than just libraries there are
also a wealth of
useful data sets that you can use to
validate your model such as the open
graph benchmark tu data set
and the data sets and benchmarking graph
neural networks
so hopefully now i've given you a
convincing argument for why it's useful
to study gnns
if you'd like to see a bit more of these
bleeding edge applications i've given a
much longer talk on this at eml 2020
which is available on youtube and you
can check it out
what i want to do today is to give you
good blueprints and context if you want
to study the field further
so i'm first going to drive gnns from
first principles and then position that
in the context of
several independently studied directions
that ended up deriving
essentially the same idea so hopefully
this is a perspective it will be useful
both to newcomers that are looking for a
good survey of related work
and implementations to check out and
also seasoned graph new network
practitioners who might benefit from
this particular perspective and way of
looking at it
of course i welcome any and all feedback
so please let me know during or after
the talk
how you liked it the content is based on
my current collaboration with john bruno
michael brownstein and taco co and i'm
categorizing geometric deep learning
and you can see various contexts that
i'm going to present here within chapter
7
of will hamilton's excellent graph
representation learning textbook
i also put some thought into the
historical context behind everything
here and i would like to thank the
researchers outlined here for
at various times presenting me with
useful insights
that i placed within this talk but of
course any errors in admissions made are
mine alone and please let me know if
there's anything that
i have misrepresented during this talk
finally
before we get into everything the talk
content here is geared to a general
computer science audience we'll just
build useful functions that work over
graphs and we will use concepts that you
can commonly see in a computer science
curriculum
if you actually want to get started with
implementing any of
these models it will require a bit of
background in machine learning with deep
neural nets
and you can use the great deep learning
book to get started
in the area by good fellow benjamin
corville i recently put up a twitter
thread which lists many useful graph new
network resources
and when you feel ready to start
implementing alexa gorditch has recently
put out a very influential github
repository
that presents our graph retention
network model from the ground up and in
my opinion it's probably the most gentle
way to get started with the
implementations with all that out of the
way let's get started and let's try to
drive gnns
from the first principles so we will see
how we can define useful functions that
operate over graphs and
basically we're going to study what are
the properties that are useful for a
function to operate meaningfully over
graphs
specifically what are the symmetries and
invariances that a graph neural network
should ideally preserve
and to kind of jump into the study i'm
going to revisit the known example that
you've seen if you've done any kind of
image processing
is this idea of an image convolution and
here provided a brief animation of how
it works
you have this small kernel matrix k
which is slid across an image and
locally captures patterns of interest
around the image
so what this kind of model encodes is
this concept of translation and variance
it means that a pattern is interesting
no matter where
i find it in the image that's why i
slide the matrix across everywhere
also it encodes an assumption of
locality pixels that are close to each
other are probably going to be far more
strongly related
than pixels that are far away in the
image so these
concepts are very useful for images what
might be the case for graphs
and in the case of graphs you might look
at them for a little bit and realize
that
if you don't assume any particular
geometry to them then the nodes of a
graph are assumed to be not given in any
order and that means if i give you two
graphs that
are completely isomorphic here i've
given two examples of
if you look at them you will see that
they're actually the same graph we would
want our graph neural network to give us
exactly the same result for those two
graphs and
what we're going to do now is see what
are the basic building blocks we can use
to enforce
exactly this this will bring us to the
concepts of permutation and variance in
permutation equivariance
in order to simplify the setting for now
i'm going to assume that our graphs have
no edges so we just have a set of nodes
v
and in each one of those nodes we may
have a feature vector x i for node i
and the way in which we typically
process this in graph representation
learning land
is we stack these row vectors into a
matrix
of shape n by k where there's n nodes
and k features in every single one of
them
that is the i throw of the matrix
corresponds to the i feature vector
and one thing that's very important is
that just by the act of stacking the
nodes you've specified an
order in which you're visiting them and
we would ideally like any result of
applying a graph neural network to
not depend on an operation like this
so it's useful to think about what are
all the operations that might
just change the node order and do
nothing else you may know from
mathematics operations like this are
known as permutations for n nodes
there's n factorial many of them
and it's very nice that we can think
about permutations and stay completely
within the realms of linear algebra
because each permutation defines a
unique n by n matrix here
given a matrix for the case of two four
one three
each of these matrices are called
permutation matrices and they have
exactly one
one entry in every row and every column
everywhere else they have zeros
and as you can quickly see by a matrix
product with one of these row stacked
feature matrices
the only effect they have is to uh
permute the order
in which you have your vertices and
nothing else so these matrices are very
useful as a tool to study this further
so in order to design functions over
these set matrices x
that will not depend on the node order
we basically want to say that
if i were to apply a permutation matrix
to the input that is if i were to change
the order in which i present you the
nodes
that shouldn't change the result so this
gives us a very useful notion of
permutation and variance
and we say that a function operating
over sets is permutation invariant
if no matter what permutation matrix p i
apply to the set before applying the
function
i'll get the same result uh anyway like
as if i never did the permutation in the
first place
you might have seen some models that
exhibit permutation variance before
one very generic form is the model
presented in the deep sets paper
published at nurbs 17
where you basically represent the
function over sets
as some independent function psi applied
over the row vectors x i and then you
perform some permutation invariant
aggregation function which is agnostic
to the ordering
something like summation maximization or
averaging
and then afterwards you might also
stitch an extra function at the end this
phi function
that operates over the aggregated
representations and because you have
this critical sum aggregation
you're able to summarize your entire set
in a way that is independent of the
order of the nodes you've provided
now this is a very good way to obtain
outputs on the level of entire sets
because we're aggregating the entire set
but what if we want to do predictions on
the level of individual nodes
now if we want to do that we don't quite
need permutation and variance we need
something a bit more fine-grained
we want to be able to once we've
performed our function on sets to still
be able to identify
what part of the output belongs to which
node and a permutation invariant
aggregator would pretty much destroy
that because it would kind of crunch
together all the nodes into just a
single vector
so what we might instead seek in this
case are functions that don't
change the order of the nodes that is if
i have a permutation specified by a
permutation matrix p
it doesn't matter if i permute the nodes
with it before
or after i apply the function the
function itself will preserve the order
so accordingly we can define the notion
of permutation equivariance
if no matter what permutation matrix i
throw at this input
it doesn't matter if i threw it before
or after
i applied the function and that's neatly
summarized in the equation below
now with this we can say that
equivariance mandates that every node's
row
remains unchanged after i apply this
function and we can think about it
basically if we
focus on the function as operating row
wise this will be a very important
perspective when we move to graphs
so we can think about permutation
equivalent functions on sets
as these psi functions that are
independently in isolation
applied to every node i giving us
latent vectors h i and once you stack
the h's you can get a latent space
matrix h which represents the features
in each of your nodes
once you've applied the transformation
combined with invariance this gives us a
very powerful blueprint
if we stack together these equivalent
functions that
transform each node in isolation
potentially with some invariant tail if
we're interested in like
results in the level of the entire set
this gives us
many useful functions on sets arguably
this is as far as we can get with basic
sets without
assuming or inferring additional
structure which i will
get into later on during this talk so
now that we have these concepts
of invariance and equivariance on sets
we can try to transfer them to graphs
and it turns out to transfer quite
easily
so now we assume that rather than just
having the nodes we also have some edges
between them so we have
a set of edges e which is a subset of
the cartesian product of the nodes
and we can often represent them
conveniently with this
adjacency matrix a which has one entries
wherever there's an edge and zero
otherwise and
there are other additions you can add to
this like edge features edge types and
so on but i'm deliberately ignoring them
to keep the blueprint simple
it's usually quite easy to introduce all
of these things back
and the main things we want permutation
variants and equivariance they still
hold
we just need to express them slightly
differently so the main difference now
is that when you apply a permutation to
the nodes you're also applying a
permutation on the edges right
because the rows of the node feature
matrix correspond to both the rows and
the columns of the adjacency matrix
you need to apply a permutation matrix
to both the rows and the columns of a
in isolation and this is conveniently
written down as p
ap transposed and this just gives you
updated versions of the invariance and
equivariance
rules for graph structured inputs just
as before
so now our function takes in node
features as well as an adjacency
and if i were to permute the inputs and
the adjacency appropriately
it for invariance it doesn't matter if i
did it before or after and for
equivariance i'll still be able to
identify all the node features
regardless of whether i've done it
before or after now
this is a concept that very clearly
generalizes but there is something extra
we have on graphs that we couldn't quite
do on sets
uh like as we mentioned on images we
really like this notion of local
functions
functions that operate only over a
locality of a certain node
and graphs give you a very nice context
to do that which
is the node's neighborhood so for a node
you can define its one hop
neighborhood as all of the nodes that
are adjacent to it so there exists an
edge connecting them and accordingly
you can extract the set of features that
are in the neighborhood by just pulling
out all the x
matrix rows for the nodes which are in
your neighborhood and i've denoted this
as
x and i to denote all the feature
vectors
off the nodes adjacent to node i and
if you want to define a local function
you can say that now a local function g
operates over a node and over this multi
set
of node features and this gives us a
graph
a recipe for generic graph neural
networks because now if you want to
build a generic permutation equivalent
function
you can just appropriately in a shared
manner apply this
local function g over all of your
neighborhoods so
and you stack the resulting latents as
different rows of a matrix
and in order to ensure that this thing
is still equivariant we need to make
sure that g
does not depend on the order in which
you present it at the neighborhoods
so g should be typically constructed to
be permutation invariant to the entries
of x
and i and this is just to give you a
visual of everything that we've covered
so far
we're going to express graph neural
networks as a local
shared function g applied to every node
and its neighborhood in isolation
and as a result of applying g we will go
from input features
x i to latent features h i
and here i've given this one example of
a node b and its local neighborhood in a
graph containing nodes a
c d and e usually we also include node b
itself and this function then transforms
the neighborhood
into the next step latents now once you
have a gnn like this i'll just quickly
look back at how you can use them to
solve actual problems specified on
graphs
so imagine i give you a graph with some
input features x and some adjacency
matrix a such that x i
contains the features of node i applying
a g n on it
transforms these x's into latent
features by being mindful of their local
surroundings
and now if i have a node classification
task
i can look at each of the nodes latents
in isolation and learn a classifier on
them
if i have a graph classification task i
can use
again a permutation invariant function
such as sum to combine all the nodes
into one representation
and then apply my graph level classifier
to classify them
and for certain kinds of gnns if you
want to
predict uh properties of edges or even
existence of edges
which is known as link prediction you
can also build a function that operates
over the latency of the two nodes and
potentially any edge features you might
have between them
so this is the general recipe of once
you have a genen and you use it to get
equivariant latents how can you then use
those latents to do anything else that
might be of interest
on a graph so once you have a grasp of
this main blueprint
let's see what are the ways in which we
would typically instantiate them
so as mentioned we construct this
permutation equivalent functions
f by sharedly applying a local
permutation invariant function g
over all the neighborhoods and under
various guises you might have seen g
referred to as either diffusion
propagation or message
passing and now we're going to look at
ways in which we can actually define g
this is obviously a super intense area
of research but very fortunately for us
almost any layer that gets proposed
nowadays can be classified as one of
three spatial flavors of genomes
and they are the convolutional
attentional and message passing flavors
which i will now present to you
one at a time so first of all in the
convolutional setting
we are just giving an interaction
constant cij
that says how much do i value how much
does node
i value the features of node j and then
they're basically coefficients in a
well weighted sum or different kind of
weighted combination
of locally transformed features so i
have a psi function applied to every
node feature in isolation
i aggregate them by weighing their
contributions using the cij constant
and i use some permutation invariant
aggregators such as sum
to combine them and then that gives me
the recipe for the features of that node
in the next step
usually these weights cij will depend
directly on what's in the adjacency
matrix
and some famous examples are the
chebyshev networks the graph convolution
networks and the simplified
graph convolution networks they're very
useful if your graph is thermophilus
because
when your edges encoded labels should be
similar you can usually just get away
with doing a very simple
average of what's inside your nodes and
it's also very useful because they're
very scalable like if you know your
graphs are going to be homophilus this
kind of model is very lightweight and
easy to implement using simple
matrix operations and as a result it's
much easier to scale to say billion node
graphs
then if you want to make things a little
bit more complicated like let's say your
edge is no longer just in code for label
similarity but there could be
some repulsion effects for example if i
retweet someone it doesn't mean that i
entirely agree with them
i could actually thoroughly disagree
with them we just replace these constant
fixed weights with weights that are
learnable
and this if you've done something like
transformers in the past might be
familiar to you as an attention
mechanism
it is any function that takes features
of the sender node
and the receiver node this a function
here and it gives you a coefficient that
you can use
to weigh that node's contributions to
the receiver and this is one very
elegant and powerful way to learn more
complicated weighted combinations
but it still doesn't require that much
information to be computed and stored
there's several models implementing this
idea some of the earliest ones include
the monet model
the graph attention network and the
gated attention network
that are listed here and they're very
useful as a sort of middle ground like
if your edges do not encode
strict homophily relations you might
want some more complicated sums
but you still want to just only compute
one scalar for every edge so it's still
reasonably scalable
this is the choice that kind of offers
the middle ground between the two
and on the far end of the expressivity
spectrum you have the message passing
gnns
where the sender and the receiver work
together in this
psi function to compute an arbitrary
vector based message which is sent
across to the receiver node
so keep in mind in the attention case we
still sent just the raw neighbors
features
weighted by some constant here the
sender and the receiver collaborate
together to compute what
the message is going to be and it's
appeared under various guises within
interaction networks message passing
neural networks and the graph nets model
and they can be seen as the most generic
gnn layer as a result
this means they can fit some very
complex simulation data like
algorithmic reasoning physical
simulations or computational chemistry
but that could imply some scalability or
learnability issues because now you have
to store
and compute an entire vector for every
edge in your graph and there's typically
a lot more edges than there are notes
so now once i have covered this
basic blueprint and the three basic ways
in which you can instantiate it
well you can see that presented in this
way it looks quite clean but
one thing you can remark is that we
didn't actually start researching graph
neural networks from a blueprint like
this
and if you've studied graph neural
networks especially a few years ago you
haven't seen them presented in this
particular way
you might have seen a perspective like
spectacular versus spatial
or deep walk in no to vec or something
like this and the reason for that is
that graphs very naturally arise across
the different branches of science
and different disciplines have found
different tools to process them
but now i'll give you a feel for how
accurate this blueprint actually is
by surveying a lot of these prior and
concurrent approaches
and showing how in most cases they map
pretty much
exactly to this blueprint that i've just
shown you and if you've read up any kind
of graph representation learning before
there's a good chance you will have at
least seen a few of these but it's
perfectly fine if
you haven't seen some of them uh i've
left enough references that you can get
started on any of them in isolation
so the first one perhaps the most kind
of
traditional boom of deep learning on
graphs came through node embedding
techniques
and they rely on finding good ways to
embed nodes in a graph
into vectors i've taken this figure with
great thanks to will hamilton where he
used the z notation for the embeddings
i'll typically use
h and it's using an encoder function but
at the time all these encoder functions
were actually lookup tables so
you were just learning a flat
representation of every node without any
particular complicated function used to
derive it
and now the question is what makes this
h vector good
well graphs carry interesting structure
and if you have a good
representation of nodes it should
ideally preserve this structure
and what's the simplest possible notion
of structure you can have well
it's an edge so if i have features h i
and h j of two nodes
they should be somehow predictive of
whether or not say there exists an edge
between the two of them
and this gives us a very straightforward
unsupervised objective we can optimize
these h vectors to be nearby
if they formulate an edge or far away if
not
and this allows us to just take the dot
product the dot product similarity of
the two nodes will tell us
what the estimate of this value is and
then we can optimize it using standard
binary cross entropy make these dot
products high
for edges in the graph and low for non
edges in the graph and this is actually
just a special case of a far wider
family of methods called random walk
objectives
which tried to make this a little bit
more interesting by refining the
condition from
they should be close together if they're
in an edge to
they should be close together if they
co-occur in a short random walk so this
allows you to slightly expand your
receptive field
it should be noted that this dominated
unsupervised graph representation
learning before gnns became a thing
and you've if you've been around that
area you've probably heard of approaches
like deep walk or note to back or
line which are sort of the flagship
papers that uh spearheaded this area
but one thing that's very important to
note is that as i mentioned these random
walk objectives force the embeddings to
be close to each other
if they are close together in the graph
but what does a convolutional genuine do
it summarizes an entire set of neighbors
around you into a vector embedding
so because in most of these like small
world networks like the one i pictured
here
if you have two nodes like i and j here
that are connected with an edge
they're actually going to have a lot of
overlapping nodes in their neighborhoods
see like for the all the neighbors of i
and j
only two nodes this red and blue note on
the side
are not featured in both of their
neighborhoods so if you just apply a g
m without any particular training it
should make them have similar embeddings
just by design
and basically from a representational
perspective these deep walk style models
emulate an untrained convolutional gnn
one
corollary of that is that typically it
doesn't work that well to combine random
walk objectives with gns
and actually at times you can match the
performance of deepwalk by
a convolutional genome that hasn't been
trained at all
i first spotted this within the deep
graph infomax paper as an accidental
consequence of setting the number of
epochs to zero and
it was since then independently verified
by several other researchers in the area
so one thing that you also might find
interesting here is that there is a
clear correspondence between the node
embedding techniques that i just
mentioned
and some of the more traditional word
embedding techniques in natural language
processing
if you think of nodes as words if you
think of these random walks as sentences
you can basically equate node to vect
with the word to vec objective
and their optimization objectives are
actually near equal they even both
feature negative sampling and things
like that
and actually this is a correspondence
that continues even nowadays some of the
recent
work on pre-training graph neural
networks borrow a lot of concepts from
bert and i've left the reference here if
you would
like to read a bit more about this but
speaking of nlp
let's make a quick remark about nlp
so it's not just that gnn design is
inspired by an lp
sometimes you can see concepts going the
other way
if you look at words in a sentence
they're obviously going to interact in
some interesting ways like subject
object and these kinds of relations and
they interact in a way that's not
trivial and not sequential that means
that processing them using a simple
recurrent model or a convolution model
may not be the most accurate way to look
at them we may actually want to use a
more generic graph over them but the
problem is
what is this graph and one common
assumption when you don't know what the
graph is is to just use a complete graph
and let the graph neural network infer
what the relations are
and if you worked at all the natural
language processing over the past few
years this should sound
very familiar in fact i've literally
just described transformers to you
so this is no coincidence transformers
actually can be seen as a special case
of graph neural networks
they fall very nicely into the blueprint
i mentioned because they work on a fully
connected graph
and they use the attentional flavor of
gnns
how do you tell a transformer that it's
still looking at a sequence it's by
putting them these extra features these
positional embeddings that tell you
exactly where you are so that you're not
just looking at a bag of words
but if you were to drop these positional
embeddings you get a very standard
vanilla fully connected graph attention
network model
you can another very great perspective
looking at this is that these attention
coefficients
can be seen as a means of inferring a
soft
adjacency matrix this is a very
interesting area and the links have been
brought about in much more clear detail
by chaitanya joshi in this
gradient publication so if you're
interested to find out more about this
link i would highly recommend that you
check out this
this paper but in the meantime i'm going
to move on to
one of the most popular early approaches
to deploying graph representation
learning
you might have seen in many cases that
early papers
including one of my own would classify
graph neural networks into spectral and
spatial
i am now going to hopefully show to you
that in most cases
this divide doesn't actually truly exist
so how did we get there well one very
useful quantity from digital signal
processing is the convolution theorem
which defines an identity that is very
attractive to us because
it's allowing us to express a
convolution in some domain like the time
domain
as multiplication point wise
multiplication and some other domain
like the fourier domain
and this is a detour to defining
convolutions because
defining an operator that does
point-wise multiplication in a learnable
way something that's quite easy for us
to do
but the problem is you know the
convolution theorem and fourier
transforms are usually defined over
these
time-specified signals so what would be
the domains in the case of graphs
well to get there we will first see how
graphs come up
when you look at discrete sequences
we can imagine a kind of a time series
or a sequence as this cyclical grid
graph
the reason why i've added a cycle from
the first to the last time step is so i
can more easily handle the boundary
conditions
but generally it doesn't change the
findings that i'm going to have and we
can express a convolution operation this
is kind of by analogy to images as
something that looks at a current time
step
and maybe some immediate neighborhood of
it so we compute the
updated features of node two the h2 by
applying some local weighted sum
of node two and maybe some immediate
neighbors for example nodes one and
three
and let's say that the coefficients of
this operation
are these constants well sorry learnable
uh constants a b and c now
what's very important is take a look at
the bottom of the slide this specifies
a matrix operation that you're applying
over every time
step in isolation and we call these
matrix circulant matrices
they're called so because you can start
with the first row and then
as you go down the rows you always shift
the all of the coefficients by one to
the right
any matrix that has this property is
called a circulant matrix
and in the case of 1d convolutions it's
very evident
now one very important property of
circular matrices is that they commute
that is no matter what vector i choose
as the first
vector of a circulant matrix i'm able to
commutatively apply it with any other
and matrices that commute are also known
to be jointly diagonalizable
that is the eigenvectors of one of them
are eigenvectors of all of them that
means that they eigen decompose in the
same way
and very conveniently all circular
matrices decompose to exactly the
discrete fourier basis
of these vectors formed by the
complex roots of unity and you can very
easily compute these eigenvectors by
studying
one circulant matrix like the shift
matrix which has only uh one parameter
in the
second position now if you stack these
fourier basis vectors into a matrix
you recover exactly the discrete fourier
transform because
if you multiply by the conjugate
transpose of this matrix
you transport your signal into the
spectral domain
and this also allows you because all the
circular matrices share this eigen
decomposition
to decompose any circulant matrix as a
product of the fourier basis
times a diagonal matrix of eigenvalues
times the conjugate transpose of the
fourier basis
and from this you can naturally derive
the convolution theorem
any circulant applied to a feature
matrix x
can be expressed using this eigen
decomposition and therefore you can
first multiply your features x with
phi star to cast them into the fourier
domain and then because you're
multiplying by the eigenvalue matrix
which is a diagonal matrix
this exactly corresponds to just
pointwise multiplication
one very important corollary of this is
that as long as you know phi
these fourier basis vectors you can
express your convolution just using its
eigenvalues and not the actual
parameters of the circulant
to kind of summarize everything that
i've said so far in
the spatial domain we might apply
convolution by applying a circulant
matrix directly to the inputs x
but now i've just offered you a detour i
can instead first apply the discrete
fourier transform
phi star to transport x into the
spectral domain
and in this domain applying a
convolution is just element-wise
multiplying with that convolution's
eigenvalues
and then once i have the result in the
spectral domain i can cast it back into
the spatial domain
by applying the inverse discrete fourier
transform which is just
phi so the key idea here is that i don't
need to know what is the convolution
operation
if i know its eigenvalues with respect
to the fourier basis
and this gives us a recipe for graphs
now the problem with graphs is that
convolutions of interest
are usually far more generic than
circulant matrices
so it's really hard to reason about what
those matrices might look like
but we can still use the concept of
shared eigen bases so if we know some
graph fourier basis for our graph we can
only focus on learning that operations
eigenvalues
for grids we wanted to commute with
shifts so that's why we had the
circulants
and we can think of these shifts as an
adjacency matrix for the grid
and this can generalize when you don't
have a grid so
if you have a grid convolution on n
nodes your fourier basis was always the
same it was the n-way discrete fourier
transform basis
but now for any graph you will just
compute its own phi that's dependent on
the graph structure previously the
structure was fixed
now one thing we would very much like
our convolution to commute with
is the adjacency matrix because that
specifies the graph structure in the
most direct way
but unfortunately we cannot always eigen
decompose the adjacency matrix
so instead we choose to represent the
information in the adjacency matrix
in a way that's easily mathematically
eigen decomposable
and that leads us to the graph laplacian
matrix which is the difference of the
degree matrix and the adjacency matrix
so here you see an example a plus matrix
and you can see that it represents all
the properties of the adjacency
but in a way that's going to be shown to
be more mathematically convenient so see
you have in all the -1 entries the edges
of the graph are encoded
and along the main diagonal you have the
degree of each vertex in the graph
ordered from 0 to 5
in this case so assuming your graphs are
undirected which i'll focus on here
the laplace matrix is symmetric and
positive semi-definite which means that
we'll be able to eigen decompose it
and this means we can express the
laplace matrix as this specific fourier
basis phi
times some matrix of eigenvalues times
phi star
and now if i change these eigenvalues i
get all the matrices that jointly
diagonalize with l or i.e any matrix
that commutes with l
and we usually look at this expression
as the graph fourier transform as
popularized by john bruno at iclear
2014.
so now if you want to convolve like
apply your graph convolution into some
new feature matrix specified on the
nodes
you first multiply with this previously
precomputed phi star
you've entered the spectral domain now
you pointwise multiply with these theta
coefficients which now can be learnable
you can specify them as something that
can be learned by gradient descent
and finally once you have the result of
that product you can cost back to the
spatial domain by multiplying again with
phi
now however directly learning these
thetas that i just mentioned is usually
inappropriate because it doesn't
localize it doesn't generalize to other
graph structures it's computationally
expensive so there's a lot of problems
with directly learning the coefficients
even if it gives you a much more
powerful class of
operators instead what we commonly do to
make this tractable
is to make the eigenvalues related to
the eigenvalues of the laplacian
and usually we force the eigenvalues in
this diagonal matrix
to be a polynomial function of the
eigenvalues of the
laplacian and some popular choices for
this polynomial are cubic splines
chebyshev polynomials or k-la
polynomials
now one thing that's important to note
is that once you force yourself to use a
polynomial in the laplacian
you have defined a convolutional g n
because you can literally compute the
polynomial of the laplacian
and use it to specify coefficients c i j
in the blueprint that i previously
mentioned
and basically most like most of the
efficient spectral gen
approaches spatialize themselves in a
way like this
so basically this spatial spectral
divide that many papers talk about
is not really often a divide because the
true spectral
non-spatial operators typically don't
have the computational
performances that we would like or
localization properties that we would
like
now before moving on to the next
perspective i'd like to just briefly
look at transformer
positional encodings again if you've
read the transformer paper you'd know
that
these positional encodings in each of
the nodes is given by
these complex series of sines and
cosines that are related to the position
and sines and cosines are very related
to the eigenvectors of the discrete
fourier transform
so one could actually interpret these
positional embeddings
as eigenvectors of the grid graph and
that was the connectivity between the
words that we initially assumed like
this cyclical grid graph of
uh time series coordinates
and you can actually use this idea to
run transformers over generic graph
structures
just change these positional encodings
with some top k
eigenvectors of the laplacian of the
particular graph
that you're assuming of your data and
this was actually recently applied in
the graph transformer model from
widget and xavier verson which in my
opinion is one very
exciting direction to consider in
rougher presentation learning
so uh having finished the spectral
section i will completely shift gears
and look at it from a more probabilistic
perspective the perspective of
probabilistic graphical models
so far we've used edges in a graph to
say there's some kind of relation
between the nodes but i wasn't very
explicit about what kind of that
what kind of relation that is but we can
instead take a more probabilistic view
and say
nodes correspond to random variables and
edges are dependencies between their
distributions
this allows you to specify these notion
of probabilistic graphical models
and these edges help you decompose a
joint probability distribution
into a product of much more manageable
distributions so
in this canonical example bayesian
network at the bottom
you can decompose the overall
probability of a b c d and
e as a product of probabilities
specified by the edges of the graph and
i've kind of color coded it here so that
it makes sense a directed edge means a
direct dependence
but one particular pgm that we will
study here
is the markov random field which allows
you to decompose the joint into a
product of these edge potentials
specifically if we assume nodes can be
represented by inputs and the latent
representation that we wish to compute
so h i for node i and h i is the uh
x is the input for node i and h i is the
latent for node i
uh there we can assume that they are
related for every node in isolation
and then assume that the latents are
related to each other only according to
the edges of the graph
and this factorizes your probability
distribution
into something that's proportional to
one potential function applied to the x
and the h for the same node
and a product of potentials of pairs of
latents across
all the edges of your graph so these phi
and psi are any real valued functions
which tell you the energy of this
particular
node latent or latent latent pair and
that specifies the probability
distribution
now if you want to embed nodes if you
have some inputs x i and you want to
compute h
i you need to sample these vectors from
the posterior distribution p of
h given x now even if you know the
potential functions this
is generally intractable and you need
some approximations to actually do it
properly and one popular method that
resolves this is so called mean field
variational inference
where you assume that the posterior can
be approximated
by a product of these node level
densities q which are specified for
every node in isolation
and they're well defined and easy to
compute and sample from such as say a
gaussian distribution
and then we can obtain the parameters of
q by trying to minimize the kl
divergence or some other notion of
distance
to the true posterior p of h given x
now minimizing the scale is intractable
but it does admit
a very favorable approximation algorithm
and if you look at the final formula the
actual way in which we derive this
formula is unfortunately out of scope
we can iteratively update q of h
starting from some initial guess
by just following this formula to get q
of t plus
1 having q of t now if you stare this
equation for long enough you'll actually
see
that it corresponds quite nicely to the
computations of a message passing jnn
i've specifically isolated what would
correspond to a message function
what would correspond to a permutation
variant aggregator
and what would correspond to a final
transformation so essentially
you can embed all of these standard pgm
computations within gene and
computations the key difference is that
in pgms do you expect the potential
functions to be specified and known up
front
but here the gnn defines them implicitly
within its latents
the actual first model derived in this
way structured to vect was not it
was not in itself quite unlike typical
mpns
but recently there's been a whole lot of
other approaches that unify graph new
networks with pgms
and in my opinion it's a very exciting
area to look at for the future
finally i would like to make a few
remarks on the
booming area of graphisomorphism testing
and some
future implications so we might often
ask ourselves the question of how
powerful are gnns
they're a powerful tool for processing
graph data but they won't solve
any task on a graph accurately and one
canonical example we use to estimate the
power is the example of deciding graph
isomorphism
are we able to use the gnn to
distinguish two non-isomorphic graphs so
if you have graphs g1 and g2 that are
non-isomorphic
will i get the different embeddings for
the two of them by applying my genetic
if i cannot do that then any task where
i need to discriminate these two graphs
is hopeless because they're going to get
exactly the same encoding
and one very simple way of
distinguishing isomorphic graphs is
passing random hashes
along the edges and summing them up this
is the weiss file
lemon algorithm which as you can see in
the bottom right corner aligns really
well with computations of a com gnn
and this connection was spotted very
early including the first gtcn paper by
thomas kiff and
it explains why these untrained gnns
work really well untrained gnns
are basically relatable to a random hash
function one thing that's important to
note is that this test is
quite powerful but it does fail at times
for example it cannot distinguish the
two graphs
in red and blue that i've highlighted
here keep this example in mind i will
come back to it in a second
now one thing that's very important and
somewhat surprising is that over
discrete features graphene inlets can
only be as powerful as this test
that i just described to you and in
order to reach the maximal expressivity
it's important that your aggregation
function is something that's injective
such as a sum
graph isomorphism networks propose one
maximally expressive gnn that follows
this principle you can see the sum
aggregator over there
and you can actually start to make gnns
stronger by looking at what are the
failure cases of this wise file layman
algorithm
for example as you can see in the bottom
right corner it cannot detect that
you're in a closed
triangle which gnns cannot do as well by
corollary
so augmenting the nodes with some
randomized position features that will
tell you where you are in the graph or
counting interesting subgraphs is one
way in which we can make them a bit
stronger and we can also look at
having sub graphs of k nodes and
embedding them together which was
exploited by one two three gnns
and there are other very interesting
avenues like directional graph nets or
invariant and equivalent graphics of
hagai maron
which further elaborate on the idea of
expressive graph neural networks
now one final remark i'd like to make
here is that
things actually change quite a bit when
we drop the discrete feature assumption
so so far i've assumed that my features
in the nodes were discrete
but if my features are continuous which
is very common in real world
applications
the proof of the injectivity of the some
aggregator falls apart and here i've
just given you a few examples
where you can look at the two
neighborhoods of node v and show that
actually the sum aggregator and also
many other aggregators
will fail at distinguishing them
particularly the example it's third from
the left where both
mean and minimizing and maximizing fail
at distinguishing the two neighborhoods
so now the question is what's the best
aggregator in this case and
uh in the principal neighborhood
aggregation paper by
gabriela corso luca caballero and others
we actually proved that there isn't one
in order to discriminate between
neighborhoods of size n
when the features are continuous you
need at least that many aggregators to
fully discriminate them
and check out the paper in my opinion it
has a really cool proof that relies on
the famous borsa coulomb theorem
and in the paper guided by this theorem
we prepare we propose one particular
empirically powerful combination of
aggregators for
general purpose g nets um
finally i would like to remark very
briefly that
we use this blueprint of invariances and
equivalences to describe gnns and to
also cast many other
research lines on graph representation
learning into it
and in fact it's remarkably powerful
beyond graphs so if you have this local
and equivariant layer that looks at
neighborhoods
an appropriate choice of activation
functions and potentially maybe some
pooling layers that make the structure
more coarse
and maybe at the end some global or
invariant layer over the entire domain
you can actually recover many standard
architectures like cnns and transformers
but besides that you can also recover a
much more interesting class of geometric
deep learning architectures that sit
somewhere in the middle
between convolutions and graphs and
they may be broadly summarized as groups
and
gauges so groups might encompass some
notions of
rotational symmetry so if your signal is
specified on a sphere
it might need to satisfy certain
symmetries gauges might relate to more
generic manifolds like this human pose
on the right hand side
and alongside michael bronstein john
bruno and taco cohen
we are actively working on categorizing
these four g's of geometric deep
learning
and i've just listed a few standard
instantiations of appropriate domains
neighborhood metrics and groups that you
want to be invariant to
and how they recover architectures such
as cnns gnns
deep sets and transformers but also many
interesting
architectures in between like spherical
cnns or gauge equivalent
mesh cnns before closing off i would
like to just
very quickly mention how did we get here
like how did we come to this particular
point
and in fact you know processing data on
graphs is so important that early forms
of graph neural networks can be traced
back
to the early 1990s but they usually
looked at very specific
uh directed acyclic graph structures and
they didn't like treat graphs as a first
class citizen
and kind of the first fully proper
treatments of generic graph structure
processing happened in the 2000s
from two groups in italy the gnn
framework from
marco gorey franco scarcely and others
and
the neural network for graphs framework
from alessia mckelly
and this gen and model of glorious
scarcely and others
primarily use these recurrent style
updates which have been updated for
modern best practices by
ugely's gated gnn layer
however one completely independent line
of research that deserves to be
mentioned at the very end
is computational chemistry here's a
quote that i found
on twitter in response to one of my
threads chemistry disrupts machine
learning not the other way around
and it's a very important and concurrent
area that develop gnns from
computational chemistry obviously
graphs are very relevant to chemistry
because molecules can be naturally
modeled as graphs
and first gnn-like machine learning
models of molecular properties
arise also in the 1990s including models
like camnet and the work of baskin and
others
in fact the molecular graph net paper
that came out in 2005
already proposes many of the elements
you'd commonly find in the modern uh
message passing your owlette
and the drive pushed well into the more
later years including work on genens for
molecular fingerprinting from david
duvano
and gns for quantum chemistry from
justin gilmer
finally recall the very first example i
showed you for detecting anti
antibiotics effectively chemistry is to
this day
a leading outlet for gnns and is a very
important subfield to study
if you want to learn more about graphnet
development and implementations
on that note i would very much like to
thank you for listening
and i hope you found this enjoyable and
that the perspective was useful for you
if you have any questions you can feel
free to reach out to me offline
either via email or all my social
networks are listed on my website many
thanks to will hamilton john bruno
michael brownstein and taco cohen
for their inspiring work that helped
drive this slide deck
and i'm now happy to take any questions
thank you so much
peter i think you're muted peter there
are already
a few questions in the chat would you
like
to pick up three or four
that you think are more relevant to
for your token it's a there's an
interesting question from
from guy i think
better can you see this one
so far you've spoken about learning
repetition representations only from the
graph
however we often know something about
the vertices outside of the graph
context for example the semantics of
words which appear in a knowledge graph
what are some ways of incorporating this
information
this is a very good and very important
question which sort of relates to
kind of partial observability of the
entire system
and what i would say like one kind of
classical way in which we would
represent all this external information
is you can just summarize it if you have
no further assumptions about it you can
just summarize it as one kind of uh
global vertex which uh is connected to
everything else in your graph
so you know that something else exists
you know it interacts with everything
else you don't necessarily know how
so kind of the most natural way to
represent it is this sort of master node
that interacts with everything
within your graph now obviously there
are more clever ways you can do if you
actually know something about the
structure or the relations of this
hidden context but yeah without knowing
any additional information about it i
would say a masternode is
probably like one standard way of
tackling it okay that's great
um i thought it might sort of cheekily
take advantage of my position
chairing to ask my own question um
so you mentioned will hamilton's sort of
excellent textbook a few times during
the talk
and he finishes the he concludes this
book by highlighting two directions that
he thinks are going to be important in
the future
and obviously you've just given this
excellent talk on sort of where
dnns have come from and i thought maybe
you could comment on this
will says we'll highlight latent graph
inference
and going beyond message passing as a
formulation so
what's your perspective on this where do
you think where do you think things are
going
do you think there's another area um
yeah what do you think
yeah so thinking about future prospects
is something that i regularly
uh like to do and michael bronstein
actually put out a very nice blog on
what 2021 holds for graph machine
learning where
myself and a few others contributed a
few thoughts on what are the relevant
papers you should check out if you want
to look at
emerging trends in my opinion latent
graph inference is definitely important
so
even without improving the basic
blueprint of message passing
we can still go a super long way if we
choose the right edges
very often the edges that are given to
us in the data
are actually not the best edges for
solving the problem and actually
sometimes we don't even have the edges
so we have to make very crude
heuristics to assume them so if we get
better at techniques that automatically
extract edges that can give us a huge
boost in performance
because it might shorten the path that
signal needs to travel before it hits an
important part of the graph
even without improving the message
passing mechanism itself
that being said besides learning the
graph structure you might also find it
very useful to
um to indeed like learn new forms of
message passing which may not depend
directly just on the features of the
sender and the receiver and
kind of narrowly combining them into
representation we can look at more
interesting functions that combine the
sender and the receiver we can look at
more interesting ways to define
aggregation directions i particularly
like this directional graph networks
idea i think it's a very
very cool future approach and yeah
otherwise personally i'm very involved
in using
graphical networks for combinatorial
optimization unfortunately i had almost
no time to mention
anything about this in the talk but i'll
just say when you start using graph new
networks to solve classical algorithmic
problems
you discover a whole new wealth of
prescriptions on how to design them so i
feel like if you want to look at
where the bleeding edge is happening
look no further than algorithmic
reasoning and physical simulations
cool that's great i think we had we had
a few questions in the chat relating to
this actually so
uh maybe you can talk a little bit more
about other areas so indigo asks
uh whether there are any particular
emerging fields um with prompting
applications so it sounds like you've
already highlighted one
and then so i think related to that um
you know i think your survey was
obviously really interesting
about you know where these things have
been independently developed do you
think there's sort of like
anywhere else where these methods have
been used maybe that
hasn't been connected to the sort of
like the the family of people looking at
a gnn type methods um or if there's
something that sort of recently
become connected that you think is gonna
be a very sort of fruitful area for
people to work in
i guess you could just expand on what
you've just said yeah i guess i'll just
very quickly highlight one
area because there's a lot like i see
graphs pop up in areas where i would
never expect them necessarily
that's because they really are such
ubiquitous way of representing
information
one area that i particularly enjoy
recently and i think ben you can also
confirm this for me
is particle physics i think that
particle physicists are starting to
discover this notion of symmetries and
invariances in graph neural networks
and they're finding it quite attractive
to model uh important events especially
unlike
these high energy systems like the large
hadron collider i think kyle cranmer had
a lot of very interesting talks in the
area that i would recommend if you want
a
brief intro but just very quickly saying
i think that particle physics is going
to be a
very fruitful area of graph
representation techniques
yeah i think that's definitely going to
be the case it's another one of these
areas where the workshops just keep
getting bigger every year
um i'll just pick out some some more
questions i think
um
there was a there was a question early
on about um
relating to attention and the questions
about some tradition
it's from vadim and it says uh some
traditional methods uh often enforce
um some kind of symmetric properties uh
and they mentioned that the dot product
attention is
traditionally not symmetric um but it
still works and they ask when when is it
important to enforce
symmetry when's it not needed but you
can comment on that
that's a that's a very important
question and i would say that
generally speaking with graphs generally
and with this whole area of geometric
learning
the answer is unfortunately it depends
so you need to look at the specifics of
the problem that you're solving what are
the kinds of invariances you would like
to preserve
and then design your model such that
those invariances are
as preserved as possible i think in
algorithmic reasoning i see a lot of
examples of this
where we've recently concluded that if
you really want the best possible
extrapolation performance which is
very important if you're learning a
generic algorithm
you need to design both your features
and your systems so that what you need
to learn is basically roughly a linear
function
so you know so you can get very
stringent conditions on what your
message passing should look like or what
your feature should look like
based on the requirements of your field
so if extrapolation is very important
this is what i would do
if instead you care more about
interpolation then i would just put a
sum aggregator and kind of throw it
at the maximally expressive architecture
possible and it's usually going to
work really well so yeah i guess it
really depends unfortunately i cannot
give a
wide range of prescriptions but there's
obviously a lot of papers dealing with
these issues
yeah of course um yeah thank you so i
think i think that
there are loads more questions i don't
know how how long you're happy to
keep answering questions for they just
keep coming in um should we take some
more
yeah we can take uh we can stay until
like 4 10 or so
and answer a few more okay great um
okay let's have a look so i know there
was a question from emma who is asking
about whether
augmenting with node position uh whether
this breaks
permutation invariants yes exactly this
breaks permutation variance
if you explicitly specify a node
position as a feature
and this is actually exactly the
approach that rpgn is used which is one
of the methods that i've cited
and the long and short of it is you need
to be careful
to kind of break that well
to fix that breakage that you've just
induced and what they do
in that paper is theoretically what they
do is they actually aggregate their
prediction
over all the possible permutations of
the nodes
now of course this is a k factorial kind
of thing and you cannot actually compute
this but they've shown that in practice
if you just run it on a few randomized
permutations and you average the results
you get performance which actually
converges to the
actual performance if you use all the
permutations so like there are ways to
both theoretically and empirically go
around that problem but yes definitely
introducing these features does violate
uh permutation variance and you have to
be careful about that
okay cool um so there's a question from
from pablo um about incorporating sort
of
higher order um things like higher order
simplicities
um i think this is quite hot topic
for going beyond message passing um do
you have any
generally thoughts about this um
so things like uh incorporating
information about you know faces with
you know in higher high dimensional
cells
um yeah this is a
very promising approach i'm seeing it uh
not only in like computational chemistry
is where i've seen most of it
where you can kind of naturally figure
out parts of a molecule
like you know motifs or functional
groups and this like representing them
explicitly and assigning them explicit
feature vectors
is not only a way in which you can
increase the representational power of
your model
but also it can help you even generate
novel uh molecular structures more
easily because you start by generating
this higher order blueprint and then the
lower
order one so definitely it comes comes
up a lot
when hierarchy is necessary i've seen it
also recently in these like relational
inference approaches where
you not only reason about the objects at
the bottom but you can also think about
the wider classes of objects or clusters
of objects moving together
and generally the more of these
symmetries on higher orders that you can
bake into your model and not make your
model learn it
the model is going to have an easier
time so generally i'm very excited about
those approaches and they're already
showing
quite some promise in uh computational
chemistry approaches for sure
yeah definitely um okay so
we've got another question that's uh
from zacharias uh asking about
uh in standard cnn's we have we have
some kind of course tonight we have down
some plane
um he's asking about whether there'll be
principal ways of doing this obviously
this scenario that has been explored
within uh geometry deep learning
um but they're asking if there's any
sort of principle ways of doing this
yeah so coarsening is something that
we're actually working
within our write-up to try to categorize
it as well as possible
but for now there's been quite a wide
family of approaches proposed for graph
for generic graph structures which
seems to work well in various uh in
various settings so
in my opinion currently the most promise
comes from actually topologically
analyzing the graph structure like those
are the kinds of approaches that i think
are most robust
there's obviously approaches that look
at just the features and kind of try to
soft cluster them to course in the graph
but i feel like uh currently or at least
with the benchmarks we have right now
in graph classification we cannot quite
uh
make a cutting edge for those models as
opposed to just running a simple
graph model and aggregating all the
vertices at the end right so i would say
that currently the most promising
approach if you want to kind of
principally course in a graph
is to look at topological uh methods of
doing that like drag class
min cut pooling click pulling and these
kinds of things
are the approaches that i would
highlight there but i believe that
sometime in the future when we have
better data and a bit more principled
methods we should get to a point of
being able to more principally course
and graphs based on features as well
yeah i think it's i think it's
definitely really exciting
so we had a question from andre uh i
think this is from sort of
quite early in the talk asking about if
transformers
are dnns um why don't we just
directly use genens and nlp and what are
the disadvantages there
so i mean okay i'll give i'll answer
this in two ways the first of all the
most generic
gnm that you might have is this message
passing genetics so you could try to go
further from attention
and actually compute messages from
everywhere to every other word i believe
that it's just that
trade-off wise this obviously gives you
an expense in terms of computational
cost and representational cost
and maybe it doesn't justify the
trade-off maybe transformers are just so
easy to scale up that you don't need to
worry about the special case but i would
also like to remark that recently in nlp
there's a booming body of literature
trying to make more efficient version of
transformers
that don't attend over all the words
pairs but instead
they choose like this locally sensitive
hashes or something like that you know
reformer performer all these different
formers
and uh at this point when you apply
something like this
on sentential input i mean you're
basically running a gnn at this point so
i that would be my answer to this
question i think that everybody who
applies a transformer is applying in gnn
there's not really a distinction there
that i would make yeah i think i'd agree
yeah perhaps the better question is
uh when do we expect to just have
transformers be the only genome that
we're using
um okay so another one was um
from luger who
asks uh do you see have you seen
um i guess this would be the last
question um have you seen any exciting
recent
research lines on continuously evolving
graphs
um such as social networks or uh
abstract syntax trees
this is yes i think this is a very
exciting line of research i mean my work
on algorithmic reasoning is also
dynamically evolving because as the
algorithm executes
as a simulation runs state updates on
the graph at all times
but uh that's a very specific class of
graphs known as spaceship temporal
graphs where the graph structure is
always fixed
and you just basically have a time
series in every node and arguably
there's a lot of research going on there
very exciting for traffic forecasting
and so on but i think that it's a very
special case of a more exciting area
called dynamic graphs
where edges can arbitrarily be added and
removed and features arbitrarily kind of
interpolated extrapolated as you go
along and on those lines i know of two
models that seem very exciting one is
the
temporal graph attention network and the
other one
is the temporal graph network from from
twitter so those two i'm aware of uh try
to do a really principled
attack at this class of this class of
graphs
i think you know it's we're still early
stages there's going to be a lot more
interesting work
especially as we gather more principal
data sets data sets are always the issue
but those two i would highlight if you
want to like really get started on
dynamic
graph representation learning i think
it's a very exciting area um i think we
have time maybe for one more question
uh yeah sure so um
i mean did you see any questions that
you're particularly interested in i
think there's there's loads of things
um let me see let me see something maybe
we won't talk to you
yeah there's there's a lot of very
exciting questions here
by the way if you would like to see me
because zoom is probably going to drop
these questions after we're done if
you'd like to see answers to some of
these questions
please like i've put a twitter thread on
my twitter profile
you can kind of send the question in
there
um okay and i'll be happy to answer it
afterwards
so okay let's uh let's answer
uh the question from joao
which talks about an area that i used to
work on and i haven't had a chance to
i haven't had a chance to talk about it
in this talk unfortunately like you
mentioned a work that combines some
ideas from burke with gnns
do you think pre-training will become as
relevant in the graph domain
as it is in other areas of deep learning
uh my answer to that is an unequivocal
yes i think it's already a big area it's
just that
most of these applications remain hidden
from you because companies are applying
them to get
efficient graph embeddings but basically
in many like social networks of interest
you don't necessarily know what the task
of interest is going to be
at the time of specifying the graph so
it's very useful very cool
computationally if it's computationally
very hard to run a gnn in production
so it's much easier if you can use a gnn
to kind of bootstrap
good features using these unsupervisor
self-supervised losses
and then just use a simple mlp to
classify amazon recently put out this
peak companion paper which illustrates
this very nicely
they said we cannot use a gnn to like
online serve queries of people buying
products
so we're going to use a gnn on a product
graph to bootstrap the features and then
we're going to use an mlp in production
so i think it's a very important area
that probably many companies are already
doing it's just a question of
how much they're talking about it and in
that area you know i worked on methods
like dji
and the recently we put out a paper
called bootstrap representation learning
on graphs which i think is a very
uh exciting addition to the family
that's
attractive because it doesn't require
any negative sampling
and yeah just generally i think there's
going to be a lot more work
in this area that needs to be done
before we're really
really competitive on all kinds of
structural and
kind of the main scenarios but yeah
without a doubt
i think it's already very important and
pre-training and embedding learning on
graph nets is going to become super
impactful
cool well um i mean there's still
there's still like tons of questions but
i think
um people can just
go and get onto your uh twitter um
probably ask them that i i've actually
been dismissing a lot of the questions
that we've been answering which i think
i'll try and add those back into the
thing and then hopefully they're in the
recording
um yeah that sounds good so
i'd like to thank you all once again for
sticking around for like 15 more minutes
i see there's still quite a lot of you
and
i see i know a lot of you so thank you
so much for showing up
um i hope you enjoyed the talk i hope
you found the perspective useful
if you have any comments on how it was
presented anything you'd like to see
done differently
basically how how did you respond to
this talk in particular i would be very
much interested to hear
because like after iterating on how to
present graph representation learning
for many years i've sort of
converged to this particular direction
and kind of i'd hope
that it that it's as attractive to
others as as it was attracted to me so
yeah please let me know and thank you so
much once again uh most appreciated
and thank you ben for sharing the
session and asking the questions
well yeah i mean thanks thanks for an
excellent talk um and
yeah a great quick question session uh
you really got grilled i think
[Laughter]
cool cool all right so take care
everybody stay safe and
well i hope to see you in person at
whenever conferences become physical
again
thank you so much